[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing salazar slytherin proud
slytherin hogwarts founder and dark
wizard the lives and legacies of
hogwarts founders are more than enough
to fill a volume or two in madame
pincer's library
at least that's true of most but if we
look past the achievements of godric
gryffindor helga hufflepuff and rowena
ravenclaw then you'll be surprised to
find that very little remains of salazar
slytherin
and it's important to ask why
after all the lasting impact that
salazar made on the wizarding world the
turn of the first millennium was far
greater than most save only his
co-founders and perhaps the peripheral
siblings
why then does it seem that history has
chosen to neglect him
well i think we should start at the
beginning all the way back to the 10th
century when he was born
what do we know of salazar slytherin's
early life like his childhood best
friend godric gryffindor who he would
later join in the establishment of the
world's finest wizarding school salazar
slytherin was born in britain we can't
be exactly sure on the details but it
seems like salazar's homeland was
england or scotland
as most historical attacks were recorded
on paper parchment a small detail like
slytherin's birthplace was rarely marked
down and if it was the document on which
it was written didn't survive to the
present day
some historians suppose that slytherin
actually hailed from ireland which means
he would have been a fellow countryman
of the mighty fingal the fearless
although salazar likely moved from place
to place as his parents advanced his
education or fled persecution the theory
that he was born in ireland is a bit
more doubtful once you consider who
sutheran's greatest childhood friend was
godric gryffindor
this other founder of hogwarts was
famously born in the west country of
england and even lent his name to a
village as godric's hollow was named
after him the very same town that the
dumbledore family resided in nearly a
thousand years later while the
controversy surrounding salazar
slytherin's hometown remains the man in
which he was raised is far clearer
as you might suspect slytherin was
likely raised in a family that despised
muggles it was during his childhood that
his hatred for non-pure bloods was
forged although it might be simple
enough to consider salazar's hatred as a
simple inheritance bestowed upon him by
his parents there could be other reasons
england at this time in the 10th century
was filled with the fervor of the
anglo-saxon christian church
as they sought to purge the landscape of
pagan idols and their worshippers
magical families were undoubtedly
targeted in the attacks
surely part of salazar's prejudice was
from a sense of elitism but in the end
he might have simply used his hatred of
purebloods as a way to cope with the
butchering of the wizarding world
before joining his peers in the founding
of hogwarts salazar and renown as an
accomplished wizard like other dark
wizards throughout history salazar
slytherin was capable of communicating
with serpents as a parcel tongue he
shared this unique trait with the
creator of the very first basilisk herpa
the fowl and salazar's own distant
descendant tom riddle salazar would need
this ability when he created the chamber
of secrets some time before he was
forced to leave hogwarts but i'll get to
that story in a bit
during his youth salazar also famously
created his very own wand a magical
relic that would have a legacy of a 1000
years old
salazar originally created the weapon
out of snake wood and even embedded a
tiny piece of a basilisk within it
when we think of the greatest jewelers
of the time we often turn our attention
first to godric gryffindor who wielded
both a sword and wand in combat but
southern was no slouch either although
his ability to craft ones outside any of
his jewels the weapon eventually became
an heirloom of his family
at one point it made the journey across
the atlantic and wound up in the new
world where it was eventually
transformed into a magical snake tree
besides his wand salazar had trained
himself in a number of magical
disciplines as a legitimate the dark
wizard was able to read others thoughts
and even project visions into their
minds
while there aren't many records about
salazar's particular feats with this
discipline we can safely assume that he
rivaled the likes of later wizards
severus snape and lord voldemort
voldemort's own feats with legitimacy
while seeming effortless were great
enough to make many consider him the
greatest legitimates of the era he
regularly invaded the minds of his
enemies and was particularly cruel when
he used the skill against harry potter
like the earliest dark wizard herbert
the fowl salazar slytherin had also
mastered the ability of creating a
basilisk a giant venomous serpent that
was one of the deadliest creatures in
the wizarding world
by harry potter's time breeding and
holding basilisks in captivity was a
crime that could very well earn you
several years in prison salazar's
ability to speak parcel tongue served
him well in this field basilisks were a
5x class beast and were deemed
impossible to tame
that's why dark wizards especially those
who had a penchant for parcel tongue
were among the only beings to control
the serpents
their ability to communicate with the
giant snakes meant they could at least
steer them in the right direction
as you might suspect salazar slytherin
would use this skill to place a basilisk
in the chamber of secrets but again i'm
getting a bit ahead of myself i suppose
you might be wondering when exactly did
salazar therein get the idea to create
hogwarts well the exact dates of
hogwarts founding aren't quite clear
some suggest the year 993 while others
claim at 9.90 while nailing down the
school's founding date is tricky
figuring out how old salazar was at the
time of its creation is even harder it
doesn't seem that historians concur on
any one particular age but it wouldn't
make sense for salazar to be much
younger than his early 30s in order to
help found hogwarts
while joining his friends godric
gryffindor rowena ravenclaw and helga
hufflepuff it didn't seem like the
southern's questionable past raised any
questions you have to remember in later
years the divide between dark wizards
and their peers was quite stark but at
this point especially with the
persecution that all the wizarding
community face at the hands of muggles
slytherin's propensity for dark magic
was demonstrably far less evil than
witch hunts and burnings located in the
scottish highlands hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry allowed salazar
a great deal of freedom with his unique
vision for the future generations of
wizards as each founder had their own
house southern decided that he would
dedicate his to a particular type of
wizard slytherin didn't target the
recklessly courageous as gryffindor's
did or the senselessly loyal as
hufflepuff was known to do
and unlike rowan and ravenclaw's house
which recruited the smartest of every
incoming class slytherin preferred the
most cunning
he hated muggles that much we already
knew
so slytherin's house actively
discriminated against smuggleborn
students during the sorting hat ceremony
in fact it was in part thanks to
salazar's skills with charms that
brought the sorting hat to life he along
with the other founders enchanted one of
godric's old tattered hats and used it
to choose new members of their
respective houses it's hard to know
exactly what hogwarts looked like during
slytherin's time at the school at the
10th century wizarding academy it must
have been far different than hogwarts
during harry or even james potter's time
with muggle attacks on the wizarding
community burning through the country
salazar must have been a strong
proponent of teaching techniques that
made his students more than capable of
defeating throngs of villagers armed
with simple steel weapons
but as we mentioned at the very
beginning there isn't much known of the
life and times of salazar sutherin
and it's in large part due to how he
ended his time at hogwarts during the
early years of the school sutherin
eventually buttered heads with his
fellow founders
while his dark wizarding ways didn't
initially bother godric helga or rowena
his anti-muggle rhetoric however right
it must have been at the time didn't sit
well with the others
at one point southern lay down an
ultimatum he couldn't imagine a future
for the school if it continued accepting
muggle-born wizards into the program
even though southern was given a great
deal of freedom with his own house and
the sorting hat itself aided salazar in
rejecting non-pure bloods from his
program the dark wizard wanted more he
wanted every house within hogwarts to
enroll only the finest purebloods and
when this issue eventually came to a
boiling point slytherin found that his
co-founders wouldn't budge they thought
muggleborns were just as important as
purebloods and they couldn't tolerate
slytherin's prejudice any longer
even salazar's oldest friend dear
godrick rebuked slytherin for his
intolerance
in the end salazar felt that he was
forced to abandon hogwarts the very
school that he had spent so many years
helping to form
but he didn't leave the school
unblemished in the years to come the
sorting hat would continue to select
students based on salazar's preferences
and there was one more stain southern
left behind in the depths of hogwarts
only accessible by hidden pathways the
dark wizard had created the chamber of
secrets a secret chamber complete with a
statue of his likeness
then as harry drew level with the last
pair of pillars a statue hides the
chamber itself loomed into view
standing against the back wall
it was ancient and monkeyish the long
thin beard that fell almost to the
bottom of the wizard sweeping stone
robes where two enormous grey feet stood
on the smooth chamber floor
but that wasn't the only thing in the
chamber sutherin also placed a giant
venomous basilisk one that rivaled the
murderous beast that herpo perfected in
a prior age deep within the dungeon
salazar hoped that one of his heirs
would take up his charge to rid the
world of muggle-born wizards with the
aid of his serpent
his dreams would be realized one
thousand years later when tom riddle
accessed the chamber and attacked his
non-pureblood classmates unfortunately
not much is known about the period after
salazar left hogwarts but many believe
that he died just a short period after
creating the chamber of secrets
and that's it for this video did you
learn much about salazar slytherin leave
a comment down below
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember
my philosophy is that worrying means you
suffer twice
you